so listen to this insanity so the big
business in the house of representatives
yesterday
was passing joe biden's uh and democrats
1.9 trillion dollar covid relief bill
this happened yesterday it passed
without any republicans voting for it we
already talked about
that okay but that wasn't the end of the
legislative day for the house of
representatives immediately after
passing this bill
the covid relief bill the house went
into debate about
a gun bill and on days
when major legislation is passed very
often you will have
more news stations and youtube streams
around the world even streaming what's
going on
on the floor of the house of
representatives and it just so happened
that because the house went into debate
over
hr8 hr8 is the bipartisan background
checks
act of 2019 remember that 90
of the country supports universal
background checks on any gun transaction
period
but most republicans in the house don't
support it
and because people around the world
after the
vote on covid relief were still watching
the house proceedings
i started getting email from viewers i
got an email from a viewer in belgium
saying david did you see that insanity
that lauren bobert said about guns on
the floor of the house
a viewer in the uk wrote to me and said
david
did you see congressman madison
cawthorne
saying come take my guns on the floor of
the house
so i checked it out and it is truly the
stuff of horrors
the world cannot believe how ridiculous
a large portion of our country and our
elected officials are
on the topic of guns let's look at some
examples
here is completely vapid trumpian
republican congressman madison cawthorne
telling the speaker
i know you want my guns well try to take
them from me
you want my guns i know it we all know
it
well mr speaker you can come and take
them
with that i yield back gentlemen years
back the gentleman from new york
this is one of the foremost legislative
bodies in the united states
and madison cothorn is yelling at the
speaker
to come take my guns the world
is laughing crying horrified
you pick it uh lauren beaubert
went to the microphone and argued
against
universal background checks based on a
story
of a man beaten to death outside her
restaurant
in colorado but the story is a lie the
man she's referring to actually
died of a drug overdose not only is this
insane
it's also a lie take a look at this
there was an
altercation outside of my restaurant
where a man was physically beat to death
there were no weapons involved
he was beat to death by another man's
hands i have a lot of young girls who
work in my restaurant
and we needed an equalizer the story is
known to be a lie
so it's a fake story then republican
congressman chip
roy came to the microphone and started
referring to how he has all these
weapons
but he's not going to tell the
government what weapons he has
defiant in principled speech take a look
texans
americans the government is never going
to know
what weapons i own let me be clear about
that
it's not going to happen uh you know
people all over the world see that and
they ask
rightly what the hell is wrong
with the united states of america well
these people are what's wrong
then republican congressman thomas
massey
also argued against universal background
checks
on the basis of a hard to follow
hypothetical story
about the victim of domestic violence
who needs a gun to make it through the
night i
challenge you follow this hypothetical
story
how many of those hundred and twelve
thousand were prosecuted for that crime
of trying to acquire that gun
according to the doj twelve
one two twelve in a year
who were the other hundred thousand
imagine
just imagine now that you're the victim
of an abusive relationship and after
five years you've summoned the courage
and the resources
to separate from that relationship but
things have escalated
and now you've decided it's time to
acquire the means to protect you
and your children so you go to the gun
store and you try to buy a gun
the clerk presses the computer button it
says denied
you ask the clerk why was it denied i
don't know this happens
sometimes maybe you had a similar name
to somebody else in the database
you can't buy a gun today tomorrow next
week not ever
you've been denied so you go to a friend
friend you've known for a long time your
friend says i'd like to help you
you say well i don't know if i'm going
to make it through the night the friend
says i'd like to help you
but don't you know hr8 passed and it was
signed by the president
i can't spend a year in a cage good luck
tonight
now what's extra dumb about that story
actually there's a bunch of stuff that's
extra dumb about that story first of all
maybe the person he's describing should
call the police if they think they might
not make it through the night
unless they have the imaginary gun in
the hypothetical shootout
but the problem that congressman massey
brings up
someone might be wrongly denied a gun
because their name matches that of
someone who
actually can't own a gun whether
background checks are universal or not
we already have some background checks
like the the name confusion could happen
regardless of whether
the background checks are universal or
not it's a very strange example to argue
we shouldn't that's an argument for no
background checks
at all we already have some background
checks not really an argument against
making them universal
so absolutely incredible and the world
doesn't get it
the world doesn't why is it so
embarrassing here in the united states
these are deep cultural educational
uh religious in some cases issues
they are economic issues as well in fact
that shouldn't be written off there is
an economic
component to what we are seeing here but
we have
some of the most radical people we've
ever had
in the house of representatives and they
really have some serious problems
personal problems no doubt
uh but also these are just the last
people that we should have making law so
another humiliating day globally for the
united states brought to you this time
by the likes of lauren beaubert and
madison cothorn and some of these other
people let me know what you think when
you see these rants on the floor of the
house
and then remember friday march 26th
one day huge membership special
we had a tough february from the
standpoint of memberships
we are trying to recover i'm getting so
wound up i just punched my mic
we are trying to recover and so friday
march 26th we will be doing a mass
mailing to everybody on our newsletter
you can sign up at davidpakman.com for
the newsletter
with a one day really powerful i mean
really powerful membership special i
would love for you to be one of the
people
that gets on the newsletter and signs up
on march 26th all right we'll take a
quick break
and be back right after this one of our
sponsors purevpn is giving you 47
off a one-year plan which comes out to
less than six bucks a month
purevpn makes you anonymous online and
you can trust them they're the only vpn
with an always-on
third-party audit verifying that your
internet activity is not being logged
purevpn keeps you safe from hackers
prevents you from being spied on by your
isp
social media companies government
surveillance it lets you stream
shows and movies that aren't available
in your country
purevpn is super fast with over 6500
servers and you can use it on all of
your devices with 10
devices logged in at the same time you
can try it for a week for just 99 cents
and you'll get 47
off a one-year plan which is less than
six bucks a month when you go to
davidpakman.com
vpn the link is under this video and
you'll even get an
extra additional 10
off when you use the code pacman